two-time Big Ten Player of the Year at
the Ohio State now working for a
Westwood one and of course Fox Sports
college basketball good morning Jim how
are you good morning I'm curious I know
that you weren't doing the game but what
happened in the Purdue game against
Tennessee with the shutter and giving
the shooters space were you aware of
that rule well yeah because you got to
give them a couple ways you got to do is
you had to give him space to land okay
when he comes down off of his jump shot
so you'll see a call sometimes where a
guy might be underneath him a shooter
and he comes down and this contact and
the foul is called so you got to give
him space to land you know and a lot of
it today and I mean that call was so
tough because from our angle what we saw
during the game on the you know the
scoreboard to tell us Ron was that the
defender brushed by but then Carson
Edwards lay kind of stuck out a little
bit it caused a little bit of contact I
thought it was a bad call in the game
that way yeah but Rick Barnes said it
was a foul well I mean according to the
rule if he made contact when he brushed
by it that's such a judgment call a lot
of times soup from the official because
there's a bang-bang play and if they see
any kind of contact especially where a
shooter the way the rules are right now
there's contact especially is different
when a guy is going straight up and down
but when you come across the body and
your challenging kind of trying to
defend it and it's contact calls a
little bit that sometimes it couldn't
know where that official standard who
calls it and they can't see the little
movement of the lower limb by Edwards
and they cease contact automatically
assumes that it's the defender who
initiated so it's a tough way to lose
the game I mean they still kind of
wanted it over time but as you know that
momentum shifts so much because as the
team that's ahead at the time you feel
you have a game in your hand you had the
games in Anaheim so you saw Gonzaga
against Florida State Texas Tech and
Michigan best player on the floor last
night was who well I'm probably probably
Jerry Cobra for Texas Tech I mean
yeah a good man I mean and you know you
know what's weird oh he's not a in
today's world of trying to actually go
for points and hunt shots he doesn't do
that I give a lot of credit to Chris
beard the coach there at Texas Tech of
how he's kind of matured this young man
to understand how to be as efficient on
the court you know without hunting shot
I mean he's really good he's in the top
12 top six in the big 12 and steals and
also a six so he's not just doing it
from a scoring perspective but he can
beat you in so many different ways at
six six he has a nice pull-up jump shot
is three-point shot is probably not as
as depth as the rest of his game but
that's something that have come along
with time but i'ma tell you what man
that Texas Tech team defensively got him
in Tulsa last week mm-hmm and
defensively a car man I mean they're
they're they're they're tied together
like as one unit and that's what makes
them so tough to score again so it'll be
interesting with Gonzaga top offensive
team in the country ought to see how
they can kind of have success against
that defense talking to Jim Jackson
working for Westwood One during the
basketball tournament of course two-time
Big Ten Player of the Year at Ohio State
I was wondering last night when I was
you know watching Purdue and then I
realized that they had 16 threes and
then the previous game I think 15 3 so
31 and that's the most since loyola
marymount back in I think 1990 they were
so far ahead of their time Jim when you
look at what they were doing I mean
that's what people do now they the
Golden State will trade a two for a
three and here's Loyola Marymount what
would they be like now if they were
doing it like they were back then
they're being credible and you think
about it back then you remember let me
see the Denver team's of the later
mid-80s when they were putting up a lot
of points he came anyway what yeah yeah
they were putting up a lot of cuz a lot
about mismatches a smaller lineup Don
Nelson actually did it in the early 90s
not that it was a three
but he went with a smaller lineup a lot
with mitchrichman Chris Mullin and Tim
Hardaway
he went small ball a little bit to try
to force seem to match up but it's
amazing how the game and I'm not one of
those you know old school guys that says
you know when we play back in the day
you know with this at this and you know
the guys now couldn't play well you know
what the game has evolved in order to
grow and part of that in evolution was
not clogging up the lane had the freedom
of movement kind of more of a European
style cause it's such an international
game and now at the demographics the 18
to 34 year olds who really watch the
game you know buy the merchandise that's
what they like to see so that's the game
we have today and as much as it
frustrates a lot of people at times that
oh why don't you take the two instead of
the three
that's just how teams play and the
precedent was set back then but it took
a while 40 vaults where we had things to
Golden State don't you think this is the
impact the legacy of Steph Curry that
that will look back on this with what he
brought to the NBA at his size giving
everybody the thought that maybe I could
play that way or I can shoot that way
you know you know it's a great question
I think the timing of everything of not
only Steph but how the four in the five
position has changed okay I think all
that was going on at the same time
because you were having a guy like dirt
who was not your prototypical seven
footer European player okay
so that gave you pause in regards to
where the game was going utilizing the
three-point line and Steph his evolution
I keep in mind people forget that you
know Golden State was pretty close to
trading step but there's no big when to
resign yeah okay because of his injuries
so it just is not like Steph came into
the league and its first two or three
years the league look there Cedric said
you know what we got to go find a Steph
Curry okay it evolved into what we see
right now the iteration of this Golden
State team by getting the right people
the right philosophy and the right
coaches to realize this is what
make us more successful than the other
team so death had a lot to do with it
I think the evolution of again post
players being more versatile in that for
position so all that stuff came together
but step has been the face of what we
see today
Paul Pierce created a little bit of
headlines by saying that Diane
Williamson I think already a top 50
basketball player in the world I would I
would say yeah I I would I would put him
in the top 50 legitimate object ya know
you don't think I've ever seen him play
yet on a that's a disrespect to the guys
that are playing right now because I
haven't seen him play on the
professional level through 82 games to
see what happened okay yeah as a player
that's I'm just gonna disrespect the
guys that have been doing it for a while
that are playing that I know that can
play now there's some names based on
Tana you can say well he looks better
okay baby he looks better but we haven't
seen him in an NBA game and that doesn't
mean that he'll when he first comes in
he's not like the Brawn in regards to
what he does for the league and for
whatever team he goes to okay yeah but
this impact is much more than just
putting the ball in the basket you're
talking about a guy that whoever gets
him I don't care if it's New York this
Phoenix it is Cleveland the bottom teams
Atlanta I don't know you immediately
increase your marketing your ticket
sales now you're going to be on national
TV like LeBron my Cleveland was never on
national TV you know on your roll game
there's gonna be sold out no other
player in the draft gives you that no
other player let alone the ability that
he has the physical ability but I'm just
talking about the stuff off the court
and a lot of guys don't come along like
that now what happens once he gets there
we don't know you know hopefully he's
injury free they can grow and beat us
top 50 player because we would love to
see it well he automatically makes you
relevant is what you're saying that
doubt yeah he and it's very few guys
where there's a TuneIn factor on a bad
team where
continue to watch but you will watch
Zion Williamson but if I said you
already know what Luka Danxia can do
from the rookie er and Trey young what
they could do with their rookie or if I
said you could have their future this
isn't anything to do with finances it's
just what you do on the basketball floor
and I gave you Saiyans future Luca or
Trey young who are you taking I'm gonna
take okay you know even though we don't
know what he's gonna do and we're
looking at you know Luca and Trey and
they've had great rookie season yeah but
I think those who still have limitations
okay in regards to where they go because
from a size perspective Trey is still
smaller Luca still has some challenges
for poisonous he could still got to get
his body together but I mean that's a
great I love that analogy because you
given us something that we've seen
because Luca I saw him on three season
and I said once he gives once he gets it
he's gonna be good but it's something
about Zion right now that is special I
don't know what that is you know some
guys has had it you just don't know and
they know how to figure things out
it's just something about him because
think about it people are tuning in to
watch college basketball they tune in a
lot earlier this year yeah because of
that man and the question was was it was
it
talents transferable from college to I
mean from high school or college because
RJ beer was rated higher than Lyon was
you know nothing he's answered that
question yeah but it's a shooters league
when you get into the NBA and we know
that he he's sort of hesitant with that
shot
you know yeah who was in conversation
for the MVP well they're they're young
they're better player he's a better
player than Zion obviously well yeah but
obviously but here's the thing though
the thing that Yanis makes Yanis great
of course he's 611 that's always with a
handle here's a bit with the handle his
ability to get to the basket despite you
backing off of him okay Zion has showed
in college his ability to put it on the
deck attack and then make a play
okay so at that 3/4 position probably at
the four position there he'll have a
mismatch a little bit and he'll be able
to create off the dribble and do some
things until his shot hopefully comes
around what if I said you could have
been Simmons future or as I am I'm sick
as I tell you in Simmons to me is so
reluctant as a offensive play and I you
know he wants you he's not a true point
guard I had a few times during TNT games
this year
when Ben determines that he wants to be
Ben oh he's tough but a lot of times he
doesn't do that and I haven't seen that
in him yet to kind of just he has so
much talent I don't know if he realizes
it I like somebody that is just gonna as
a motor that's just gonna go get it and
that's not taking anything away from Ben
I just don't see him in his personality
that way good stuff
I enjoyed chewing it up with you Jim
thanks for joining us and good luck the
rest of the tournament hey enjoy thanks
Dan
that's Jim Jackson two-time Big Ten
Player of the Year calling games in
Anaheim last night for Westwood one
radio for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]